hey what's going on YouTube I'm not sure
about Tojo but I'm a big fan of action
movies and when it comes to film and age
people start telling you that you
shouldn't watch action movies anymore
and should start watching [ __ ] there's a
little more intellectual well [ __ ] you
action films were the [ __ ] every now and
then you need a guide to get stabbed in
his eye and have a dynamite up his penis
and he just occasionally when it comes
to films I need to watch something with
some gratuitous mindless ass violence
but a cop movies it all for [ __ ]
revenge movies
kung fu' movies funky fish style prison
movies you ever suck a dick one of my
personal favorite action movies of all
time it's taken now for those of you who
don't know apparently there's a new
taking movie coming out and if you
haven't watched akin yet and your life
right now take it is basically an action
film where Liam Neeson's but [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of these [ __ ] that
stole his daughter now they should have
ended this movie on the first one but
they made a second and now they're
making a third god dammit now you have
to understand something about me I love
me some Liam Neeson's Liam Neeson is
like Denzel Denzel went white chocolate
look take it one was dope he comes in
and before he goes in and finds his
daughter and whoops kidnap her ass he
lays down a no pass speech I don't know
who you are I don't know what you want
if you're looking for ransom
I can tell you I don't have money but
what I do have oral - hello hello but as
much as I love me some Liam Neeson's and
I love me some taking one how the [ __ ]
did this get turned into a trilogy now
in taking two he gets caught and
apparently so does his wife so
thematically you're this boobie
everybody keeps getting taken but I
fight this to me what is still going on
in your life that everybody in your
family is constantly on the lookout of
getting taken huh
and nobody want to be your friend you
know who the students he's that one
[ __ ] that nobody wants to invite
because he's a bad luck [ __ ] you could
make the saddest knock-knock jokes out
of this fools life
knock knock who's there Liam Neeson's
hello that's cool what not y'all let's
go run away whatever listen how many
times can your immediate family members
get kids half because if you have a
particular set of skills
why won't you share them you know the
secret to not getting kidnapped but you
won't share with your family that's
[ __ ] up listen if I had a daughter and
every other week she came with a phone
call saying daddy
I think I'm hot too obviously by the
third time [ __ ] you just got took
listen if you got kidnapped twice and
you somehow got kidnapped a third time
that's called natural selection and you
gots to go and all honestly if I'm being
real as a person I can only imagine
getting the third or fourth phone call
for the same [ __ ] daddy hello uh-huh
what was that hello one aren't you gonna
come save me
the number you have a tire desirable
service the preacher Corky oh my god
what the fake I'm not saying I would
just give up but you making it real easy
if that was me and that was my wife or
daughter I'm telling you right now you
should call the cops
I've said it before and I'll say it
again you know daddy's a little [ __ ]
listen I don't want to hear all these
macho [ __ ] saying I would find
them and kill them
looky here kung pow stupid with what
skill did you work at t-mobile and you
do Tae Bo on the weekends go man down
and no that is not a situation that most
people know how to handle and if I
somehow saved you twice and then you
work on a third time
god damn it they would need to change
the name of the movie from taking to
well [ __ ] then you just got to up my
mom calling hello
hakushi Chiba Penelope Santa Anna so
kill another for a Jew GU super Oakland
family them in their position anyway cut
two people Jewish Papa didn't it